oui tout à fait le bras de fer continue
et il est bien été répété aujourd'hui
par le ministre des finances allemand
christian lindner et son homologue
français bruno le maire qui était en
visite à berlin que les contrats sont
les contrats qui ne serait pas changé et
que donc la monnaie utilisée pour payer
sur continuerait à être l'euro qu'il n'y
aurait pas de paiement en roubles
christian lindner le ministre des
finances allemand a d'ailleurs ajouté
sur la question d'ouvrir des comptes
directement avec gazprom ce qui était
également une requête de vladimir
poutine que même si la cie la suggestion
serait examinée l'allemagne comptait
bien ne pas devenir la caisse pour
subventionner la guerre de vladimir
poutine en ukraine donc une position
ferme position partagée également un
front commun avec la france avec cette
visite de bruno le maire et puis une
annonce de robert avec le vice
chancelier allemand il y aura une
réunion quotidienne entre les ministres
des finances français et allemand pour
parler de cette situation
énergétique pour parler de cette crise
énergétique provoquée par la guerre en
ukraine mais manuel les allemands
peuvent-ils se passait de gaz russe
mais c'est toute la question l'allemagne
importe la moitié de ces énergies
fossiles depuis la russie donc la
situation la guerre en ukraine a fait
changer cette cette feuille de route et
même si pour l'instant les réserves de
gaz allemandes sont encore à 25 % de
leur capacité même s'il n'y a pas de
pénurie maintenant on pense à plus tard
on pense aux prochains mois notamment à
l'hiver prochain et hier mercredi
l'allemagne a activé la première phase
d'un plan d'urgence avec robert avec
encore une fois qui a demandé aux
allemands au consommateur allemand de
réduire au maximum leur consommation
énergétique
il a effectué la même demande aux
entreprises avec des craintes de la part
des consommateurs d'une part la crainte
d'une facture élevée mais la plupart une
majorité des allemands se déclarent
prêtes à faire ce sacrifice en raison
des circonstances mais aussi une crainte
des industriels allemands de devoir
interrompre certains de leurs deux
devant fermer certains de leurs sites en
cas de pénurie de gaz en merci emmanuel
emmanuel chaze en direct de